have a ring here in my pocket I'm not
gonna use it
mm-hmm okay I mean that was the most
excruciating bachelor finale ever when
Juan Pablo did not pop the question to
Nikki he couldn't even say he loves her
but brought her to the finale video he
did say I liked her a lot
yes because with the wink and I like you
a lot he has actually considered the
worst bachelor ever it's confirmed he is
but one Pablo is trying to hang in there
trying to make things work with Nikki so
that is why they've gone straight from
The Bachelor to couples therapy I want a
plan no it's not gonna help it you don't
give me anything it's a process you're
still not listening to me it's the show
bachelor fans are dying to see how
national television saying I love you to
someone not have them say it back our
relationship with was made to look very
pretty
um you know on TV but that's that's not
reality I don't love her yet cuz that's
something more important for Latin
people it's different culture it's not
Juan Pablo still has excuses on why he
can't say I love you I love you like a
lot but we can't say we're shocked just
because he hasn't said it to me doesn't
mean that I don't say it to him I don't
expect him to say it back when I say it
maybe maybe one day he will her
housemates think it's Nikki with the
issues I get why he can't say I love you
Nikki's [ __ ] talk about spoiled can you
believe it's been nine months and the
two still can't commit to living in the
same city I live in Miami she lives in
Kansas City would be all over the place
because I've been traveling she's been
coming with me I mean visiting her she's
been visiting me and that's where dr.
Jenn comes in I still feel like I'm
waiting for
hit me you're still waiting for the
final rose I think that the public is
going to be so surprised to see the
inside workings of their relationship
but also how vulnerable both of them get
I'm having such a hard time with the
cameras with different cultures here in
this setting we have learned many things
about each other that we have no idea
and here's the mansion where it all goes
down with four other pairs on couple
therapy with dr. Jenn welcome to our
group room this room is the heart of the
house but also the heart of our work
together my love is never gonna be
enough I've been wasting my time the
best six months this is our couples
therapy kitchen where a lot of intense
stuff has gone down nothing about this
will be easy